Epic has provided a series of enhanced tools for Unreal Engine that directly integrates
with Sequencer to allow more advanced users the opportunity to expand their creative workflows.
These tools are designed to bridge the missing gaps many productions face when working in
virtual production.
Intended to promote digital connectivity, enhance performance capture, and improve cinematography
capabilities, these enhancements are a must for your workflow.
First up is Take Recorder.
This tool is like having your own recording studio in your back pocket.
Designed to record gameplay animation, live performances, camera data, and other sources
of input, Take Recorder allows artists to leverage their recordings directly in Sequencer.
By layering captured recordings together via sub-scene tracks in Sequencer, sophisticated
performances can be accomplished with a minimal crew in a highly iterative workflow.
Live Link Face and MetaHuman Animator are next.
Built around the Live Link data transfer protocol, users with an iPhone and a reasonably powered
computer can stream facial capture data directly into Unreal Engine.
When paired with MetaHuman Animator and MetaHuman Creator in Unreal Engine 5.6 or above, these
tools can generate live performances for a number of applications like digital avatars,
high-end facial capture, or streaming.
iOS devices with true depth cameras can find the Live Link Face application on the Apple
Store while other vertically head-mounted professional camera systems are also supported
with Live Link Face.
Finally, for all of you aspiring cinematographers out there, Epic's Unreal Vcam app allows you
to connect your iOS device to Unreal in order to leverage the device's AR kit capabilities.
By transmitting the iOS device's internal accelerometer data back to Unreal via Live
Link, Unreal will in turn update a virtual camera inside the Engine scene and pixel-stream
the live feed of the CG environment back to the user.
The result is a real-time virtual camera that allows the user to frame up shots by hand.
When paired with other practical camera equipment like gybs or a steadicam, professional shots
can be constructed that would be difficult to accomplish by keyframing alone.
The Unreal Vcam is compatible with iOS version 16 or higher.
And if you happen to have the Nintendo Joy-Con controllers, you can use this for camera control
as well.
And for those Android users out there, you're no longer left in the dark.
Epic has released Vcam for Android in Unreal Engine 5.4, and as long as you're running
Android device 7 or later, you'll be able to enjoy the same capabilities as your iOS
coworkers.
You can also leverage multiple Vcam users to control multiple Vcam devices in a single
session.
Okay, let's move on to our next topic.